one of the new novels in Oprah Winfrey's
book club is gaining high praise
behold the dreamers by M bolo and bowie
a is an exploration of marriage
immigration and the American dream
the story is about a young couple from
Cameroon starting a new life in New York
City during the recession
CBS this morning is Gayle King sat down
with in Bowie to talk about her debut
novel in a facebook live interview hello
CBS send in Facebook live one of us
sitting before you is a best-selling
author
now I'm Gayle King and you are in Balham
boy so that would make you the
best-selling author
welcome welcome welcome thank you good
we are very excited you're here because
listen Oprah's Book Club she announced
it on CBS Warner CBS this morning two
weeks ago and her pick was behold the
dream us
behold the dreamers by in brought home
boy and boy oh boy
listen I've been practicing her name and
she keeps saying no Gayle you're saying
it umberto not just fight Ebola isn't
yes no at one point she went okay
whatever okay but this is what I think
it's so exciting
Oprah when she has this tradition of
always calling the author to let them
know that they are the book club
selection and after she called you she
said it was one of the best author calls
she's ever had he was so excited after
talking to you so let's set the scenario
you think you're getting a call from oh
the Oprah Magazine that's right to tell
you what soli here by the book editor
she called she it was me I said I wanted
to do it want you to do a review for a
magazine book with you and I said okay
and then she said that stuck on Friday
and shift we I was to talk about the
book with you through Yahoo what kind of
book in about three hours so I got
suspicious but I didn't really allow
myself to think much about it I thought
it might be new I thought might be
something to do for the magazine maybe
write a really big essay or something
well note yourself to totally never tell
anybody nobody wants to give three hours
for now anything I said three hours I
spent three I was waiting by my phone
looking at my phone like this over three
hours oh man finally at Poly 2:45 you
should
me too him to wait for the call at noon
so between noon and 3:00 so from noon to
2:45 has sat by my phone looking at see
oh my god and finally around 2:45 I get
a call and this high below is over Oprah
Winfrey oh man and I said I thought it
would be Lee she said no it's miss Oprah
Wow and you thought what I think I was
almost more speechless you know it was
one of those moments where you know
because she sounds exactly like Oprah so
you think it is Oprah call it me on my
phone Wow
she went straight just to me immediately
she said I'm calling to tell you that
selected your book photo you know my
book I totally lost it I mean I was I
was crying party for most of the yeah
because I was so overwhelmed and not
only because of economy but because you
know my writing career has so much to do
with Oprah
you know recommending a book that
influenced me to become you know to
start writing that's what I think a bowl
is so great about this story because
here you are you come to this country at
17 what from camera we'll get to get to
that in a second but at 21 you're
watching The Oprah Show and she picks a
book that you thought what was a book no
no she don't get to pick the book before
I discovered it I walked into a library
you know host George Virginia and there
was a shelf that had Oprah Book Club
picks
okay just Oprah Book Club pigs she don't
need to pick this book years before I
think and when I and when I walked in
this is 2002 I walked into this library
there's this shop and he had all these
open book club pigs and I thought to
myself I'm gonna try one of it I've
never tried any of the Oprah oh okay
I've never I knew of the book club
because I was a big fan of Oprah you
know the show so you just happen to pick
which book I just happen to pick some of
so long song and sound by Toni Morrison
your magazine that's right because it
was an Oprah Book Club pick but because
I saw you there and it caught my eye you
know I you know I didn't ever get Toni
Morrison I didn't know much about her
work but I taught Song of Solomon what a
great title yeah so I said let me try
this book so you read the book and it
did what for you or to you and I thought
you know and I said this to the magazine
that thought if God we're a writer this
is what you write this is how we write
I just thought you know Tony Morrison
was funny just this incredibly this
wonderful gifted writer and and I was so
blown away I remember staying up at
night thinking about this book I'm
thinking what is it like to write a book
I mean what is it like to write a
powerful book and then it began you
thought did you think maybe I could do
that I just thought that right and I
didn't think about it I didn't think
that I want to publish a book I didn't
think that I didn't think about what I
wanted to write I just wanted to write a
story to experience what it's like that
was as powerful as that right you know
what I love so much about your story
because on page 195 the character in the
book nany knotted on the sofa without
taking her eyes off her Oprah Magazine
so the character in the book is reading
Oprah Magazine and then Pinter please
Patti
here is the author with I think that is
so cool yeah I mean so you wrote that
long before and listen this is our cover
this is the July cover that's and we had
shot this in Oprah set I want to be
holding behold the dreamers right in
July so we changed the book so not only
you're on the cover of Oprah Magazine
but then here you are with Oprah in oh
it's very character is reading The Oprah
Magazine right I'm so cool I never even
taught at any moment while writing this
book that Oprah would ever read it I
just know I mean why would I think I
mean Oprah with a lot of book but why
would I think she read mine never cross
my mind that she even noticed it but I
love telling the story of how I became a
writer because one of the top people
about my journey as a writer yes and how
is somebody recommending a book how much
it ended up changing my life yes but
people said to me like wow what a great
story and I said yeah but there's so
many people would like to change by
Oprah because she said something or do
something and they changed careers or
lost weight or did something so I
thought master is just one of thousands
of stories about people would did
something because of oh and I bet people
would say you should tell Oprah this
story right how am I gonna tell my story
and yes Pauline lots of studies all the
time I didn't think man was that we
market would that you know I needed to
tell her but when she called me I said I
have to tell you this terminally I
should never
oh she hadn't she said what I never had
this study she called me and said you
were not gonna believe what I just
talked to the author and she told me
that because she read bubble the story I
just told so I think it's sort of a full
circle right bomb but I meant to be mom
died here we sit here on this date in
2017 and you are her book club selection
so you came to this country from
Cameroon at the age of 17
what did you think America was going to
be why did you want to come here and
what did you think America was gonna be
like well I came here to go to college I
had relatives who you know sponsored me
to come here and I went to college
before coming here I did not have a very
accurate picture of America I think a
lot of it was based on what I've seen on
TV you know Beverly Hills you know shows
like that you know shows like Cosby Show
uh-huh I mean America seemed to be this
wonderful players people with wealthy
and healthy and happy I didn't see a lot
of the you know the not so wonderful
parts of America coming with me on TV
because it does have a is wealthy and
wonderful but there is another side
another side I did not see much and also
the immigrants who went to America and
it came back home they did not exactly
tell us that we don't have this easy
life in America I think there's a lot of
pressure to put up this facade of
success so when you come back home to
visit you don't see you know I'm
struggling I'm working for jobs you say
oh I'm doing well and you come up with a
lot of money and I did the same thing to
when I went back home I had to program
money to buy my ticket to go back home
by didn't tell anybody that you didn't
tell anybody how hard it was no no
because you come to this country to
become successful and to fail at it it's
quite shameful yeah and so when I came
here I was surprised to see homelessness
you know I've never heard of racism this
it was just all very new to me that you
know that there was just a lot of you
know social issues in this gun so you're
surprised to see homelessness in races
yeah Erika yeah if you're used to seeing
Beverly Hills yes anybody was very naive
on my part but I was young and I was
influenced a lot by the media and even
the books I read they did not you know
without any kind of image that America
was in this promised land of sorts yeah
that there's another side right so you
get the idea for behold the dreamers
this is what's so interesting because
you have the two worlds intersecting
so you're here in New York City you go
to college where did you go to college I
want mundo koala game on one guts in New
Jersey so integers and then I moved on
you have to go to Columbia Records okay
so you're you're in the city you're
walking out of a Columbus Circle
mm-hmm and you see what that sparks an
idea for you
I see chauffeurs waiting for waiting in
front of the time when a building which
is why the Columbus Circle right and I
saw this your first waiting a good
number of chauffeurs and I also saw the
man that I drove who will seem like
executives yeah and I thought what is
the relationship like between these
chauffeurs and demanded drive yeah that
was what sparked the idea so you have a
wealthy white man that's right it was
very successful
working in the financial industry mm-hmm
and the other character Jen Day is an
African immigrant mhm who happens to
come from your town that's right okay so
he gets his job and then you start
thinking what's the relationship between
the two of them or what what was your
thought there but my festered was a
buddy financial crisis because I had
lost my job at this point and lost my
job I was working for a media company in
marketing and I lost my job so I was
thinking well how did the financial
crisis affect all that people in New
York City because my I had lost my job
you know
a year after Lehman Brothers collapsed
and I thought how how did this chauffeur
how how did Lehman Brothers collapse
affect him and this executive what if
you worked on him and booed us what was
it like for him working at Lehman
Brothers and how did didn't dream she
had for themselves and their children
how were the dreams affected by the
financial crisis oh it was very much
about the financial crash yeah because
if the financial crisis it affects
executives it would certainly affect the
people that were there but in different
ways and I want to do you know explore
those different ways and also their
families their wives and their children
and the people who work for them in
different like the the secretary for the
executive you know no mega house a care
guy layer who's the secretary right so I
so instead of been mostly about a
financial crisis there because gender is
an immigrant you know I was wanted to
explore coming to this country and and
having such high hopes the way I had
high hopes for Marilyn came right when I
came and then and then the financial
crisis happens and you how you start
questioning but then you wonder about
the relationship between
two of them when their cuz they spend a
lot of time and hard together so were
you thinking what do they talk about
more do they talk right right I thought
about that a lot because I said what you
know they're very different it can be
any more different very different world
son and I wanted to you know because
class is an issue which I grew up alone
that didn't go up a long ways but I grew
up in a very class conscious society and
ii met two men like that you know a man
initial fado be very little relationship
between them because of the class but in
America I thought you know somebody like
Clark what if you went more friendly
what if we're more open-minded and how
with genders for cases is a successful
executive and a sister right
my clock is that Lumumba das a second
yes so I started writing you know the
dialogue you know when gender goes for
job interview which is where the book
starts when gender goes for job
interview and how nervous and how never
get it right I can say without giving
anything away he does get that he does
get the job Clark is married to Sandy
and Jenn Dee's married to Nene
mm-hm and they each have children mm-hmm
so along the way there's a story listen
you even top you even touch on opioid
addiction mm-hmm we won't say who has
the opioid version and and how that
turns out for them but I thought it was
so interesting and timely that you even
touched on that what made you think
about that opioid addiction well I think
I'd work in a mental health clinic and
I'd worked with substance abusers and I
was always very I'm very affected by you
know how much addiction changed people's
lives and how you affected them on their
families so I thought about these
characters having struggles I'm one of
them being an addiction and how the
amount of shame that came with that and
how another character might try to
manipulate the situation for their own
advantage yes so that's another story
about the characters opioid addiction
and there's also storylines about the
marriage between the two couples how
they're each dealing with their own
issues in their individual marriages but
what struck me is there are a couple of
times in the book where people do things
that are totally out of character mm-hmm
and so I found myself gasping like well
he would never do that and to that you
say what well I said that yes we do have
you know our current that we should
mostly live by that but we do do things
out of character Alice I know that
things out of character what have you
done it's out of character tell me oh
okay I'll tell you a story how many
years ago this is totally out of
character for maybe one time I was
driving to work and I was running late
and I was very very nervous about going
to work I may be losing my job and it
was Christmastime and the garage was
very full and somebody had a parking
spot we're about to move into and I
swerved and couldn't spot that was very
ugly but I needed to get to work ASAP
but they needed to get to work everybody
[ __ ] I was like what get out of your
car and walk away I worked under honking
I'm giving me the finger
yes but it was even though I'm thinking
I can't believe I did that
did you feel badly about that I did
because the guy was may be here so
important to be also and he was already
you know I mean he was right today and I
just went I got no you said that's not a
character for you but you said desperate
people do different yes and that wasn't
that is my example if I get your tire
slashed
oh I bet I'll spend the whole day I walk
very nervous about a carcass once I was
on the highway driving and my kids are
in the back they were younger and
somebody cut me off right and I sped up
to catch them the late and the kids go a
mom which is really bad mom mom stop and
I'm and the lady looked at me and she
went sorry all I could do was going
that's okay felt like an idiot made such
a big thing really it's a lot of it yeah
and then I realized she hadn't even
intended the cutting right but she tried
right and I was zero to 80 right and
with even with the kids in background
I'm Hawking ba ba ba so that's out of
character yes I wasn't is that that I
wasn't proud of it I am not funny I'm
never where am i that guy yes I am sorry
she's not thinking a bucket but it's it
so your point is when people are
desperate or inner minds
you don't say we'll do things in our
character and yeah that happens a couple
of times in this book yes the other
thing I like I love your writing Thank
You number one let's go to 237 you said
a man this is a can I say who the couple
is or no the line says the man who
promised to take care of her was
standing above her vomiting a parade of
insults Wow
can I say which cafe okay so this is the
driver talking to his wife yes and they
have a little tiff yes but the man who
promised to take care of her was
standing above her vomiting a parade of
insults where does that come from
thank you that is actually you know if
point in their mileage when it's very
tense time in their marriage and because
in the beginning of the story they're
very happy very happy you know they
don't have a lot in turn yeah they don't
have a lot but they they have to
confront the harsh realities of being a
working-class immigrant in America but
it's like that's so visual though
because anybody who's been in a marriage
has had a moment with their spouse I
would imagine where they're you're just
pissed at each other right and you
thinking but we're supposed to love each
other why are we talking to each other
this way so I thought that I loved that
writing and then 27 you said he was
Trevor Susan okay
scattering all questions all over him
like confetti on a victorious warrior
yeah and this is doing happy at times
yeah but she was so excited and I can
see as a wife that you're asking so many
years at the same time but the way you
said scattering questions all over him
like confetti on a victorious warrior
mhm
Wow where'd you get that from I think
it's just common you know I think it's
very visual yeah I think you know what
it is I think when I write I see things
very clearly I think that it's very yes
I just see it and then I just write it
as I see it but I don't know how to
explain it no but I thought that that
was beautifully said now this is your
first book mm-hmm how old are you can we
say me 36 yes you this is your first
book that you've ever written and the
first time you get it published how does
someone who has had no writing
experience really even get a book
published for the first time which by
the way could I mention while we're
talking to Ebola way yeah it's not the
whole
the dreamer instantly after it was
announced became a New York Times best
seller that's right so how does that
happen that it becomes how does it
happen that somebody with really no
connections who doesn't have who's never
written before get this published did
you have an agent did you have a friend
did you know somebody and what happened
and you nobody in the publishing was
hanging nobody it just took a lot of
emails to agents I did you get a lot of
rejection a lot of oh my god it must
have been I don't know maybe hundreds I
got it how long did it take you about 3
years 3 years so I so I had spent nine
years writing if I started writing this
book because after I read some of
Solomon I said that writing another
story but it still sleep in my computer
and then I decided to start writing this
one when I got the inspiration and I
started emailing agents and I emailed
lots of agents telling them you know I
have this story about this African
immigrant and the Lehman Brothers
executive are you interested exactly
but and a lot of the rejection was
because the story just needed me to keep
on working on it yes that you know you
have something special your some of them
did they say yes on the especially keep
walking today the rejections really hit
you know I need this hat how did you
keep going with rejections and had you
set a timeline for yourself that okay if
I don't make it by X date I'm gonna do
something else well I think what kept me
going was a passion yes I think I love
to write and I thought I'm gonna buy
this story and if nobody ever VC that's
fine but I'm gonna write in a key point
trying to to get an agent and my plan
was to stop trying end of 2014 2014 yes
so after that training 2011 and I said
okay after three years or say maybe
nobody wants this to me and it didn't
get published in 2014 no they got
publishing it took three years for it to
come out so you kept going even
everywhere after after I was massacred
on a journey and 2014 and Asia's so did
like very quickly I okay and then it
took a few more so finally you got an
agent who said I like it
where she said she said this is good it
could be better you know but I'm gonna
represent you which was a very big step
because when you know when you're coming
from nowhere like I did you don't have
any connection to have somebody with the
top agent my agent was a represent
Jonathan Franzen Jonathan Franzen
right so aim Suzanne go long okay so a
key Suzanne hi and so when I had this
really big agent call me which was
politic because things happen to me at
that point because I had been trying for
almost three years I'm finally I got a
call from this woman saying I think
you're something special I'm going to
represent you and then she represented
me and then I did more walk on it and
then she sold it and then I did more
walk again well you do have something
special you are a best-selling author on
the New York Times and on the charts and
Amazon and we're so happy for you thank
you cheering you on may I just say I
wanted a different ending okay I wanted
a different ending but it's a really
really good read and you just disagree
on how it should have ended yes but I
kind of just a comment from the peanut
gallery
how many best-selling books have I
written none thank you high five cbsn
we'll be right back good book